ac is with us in Ohio
hi Casey how are you I'm doing good
thank you guys so much for taking my
call
sure yeah how can we help uh yeah we are
me and my girlfriend are very new to
your guys uh do you Dave and we have
been living together for years for a
year and a half
um and I wish we wish we were turned on
to you right in there but um we're
trying to set up a budget to start
saving we're on baby step number two we
both have $1,000 saved up for an
emergency fund we both have a little bit
of debt that we're trying to work out
and we've been together five years and
budgeting has always been like a touchy
subject between us and I'm trying to
figure out the best way to set up a
budget and the best way to talk to her
about budgeting will you marry me that
would fix it that'd be the first step to
fixing it if you want to talk to her I'm
messing with you but we don't recommend
that you budget together with your
roommate only your wife because there
are legal implications and other
implications of relational implications
as well and so as long as you're going
to be roommates you need to run separate
finances I mean as if you had you know a
guy roommate from college or something
right and you still got to negotiate
over who's mustard that is in the
refrigerator and all that crap right but
you need to run separate finances and we
split the rent we split the cable bill
or whatever just like you would with a
traditional roommate but you know you
you you then begin asking because if you
want to join in on your goals and you do
that without the benefit of marriage you
set yourself up for all kinds of
problems in the event that we don't get
married because legally you own half of
this car she owns half of this car
you die now you won't have now she owns
half of the car with your mother because
she doesn't have any rights you see what
I'm saying okay yeah um so would you
just do 50/50 percent we both go in half
until we're married them own household
expenses yeah
yes and run separate budget so when
you're getting married only thing that
I'm struggling with this is she's had
some issues no he doesn't have issues
financially and she doesn't really want
to share her financing financial history
with me or basically where she's at
financially and it usually gets us an
argument because she gets kind of
ashamed about her credit card debt and
where she's at and that kind of prevents
me from wanting to get married so I'm
here's dad waited five years yeah yes in
five months it's five years so yeah I
listen you do whatever you want to do
like you said you're new to us and when
you call in here we're not trying to be
mean to your snarky with you or
something
how old are you guys we're both 26 okay
I have a 28 year old son and if he
called me with this question what I
would tell him is that as his dad what I
would tell him and I love him is that I
would want to see this marriage started
or this relationship probably sit down
with someone and do some pre marriage
counseling and start to see some of
these areas heal to where we can move
forward in the relationship because a
five-year relationship that is stagnant
is not a good that's not a good omen for
either one of you having a positive
outcome ten years from now and so I
would want to see your relationship
start to heal these areas of shame that
she's dealing with she can start to open
up and you got you can give her some
grace in those areas to where you can
see yourselves combining the mistakes of
the past and the assets from the past
and for richer for poorer in sickness
and health and I'm trying to talk you
into getting married
but because I because that's what I
would tell my own son yeah and you know
that this the sort of kind of thing
doesn't bode well for your careers your
health it doesn't bode well for your
relationship statistically the data
points and it certainly doesn't bode
well for your your wealth building yeah
there's a huge marital benefit to wealth
building yeah I think it's interesting
what he said about with his girlfriend
and the like the shame or regret because
that that seems to be like the the hold
up that's where we've got to work and
like you said do the healing counseling
whatever that looks like because if they
don't fix that that lack of trust the
lack of connection there you're never
gonna get married you're never gonna
make progress you're never going to
share finances we have to figure out
what's going on that she doesn't feel
comfortable enough to share that or what
the wound is there and once you get that
you may just realize like wow that was
that was the one thing holding us back
now we can get married combine finances
and reach our goals together and having
coached people with those same kinds of
things inside of marriage mm-hmm over
the years I've watched a lot of people
have some real good healing experiences
in the relationship by just working on
that yeah and going you know hey you
know when I went broke you know my wife
bless her heart she thought she murmured
Sir Galahad turns that was goober you
know and so there's this crisis of
confidence and it took a while for her
to have trust yeah again when they're
sitting there is such shame and that's
reasonable yeah there's such shame
around money even when Matt and I got
engaged Matt had always been a saver
still is and he had a good savings
account and I came in with debt like I
was where I was working on baby step two
whenever he and I were dating you
brought a negative net worth and he
bought a positive yeah it's embarrassing
to to reveal that to see I remember the
first time we well and to accept it that
he's gonna now you're gonna combine it
and what he's done positively is gonna
be damaged right about what you've done
relatively thankfully I actually became
debt-free the week before he proposed he
didn't know that the timing worked out
that way so I was I was on baby step two
when we were dating and then paid off my
debt the final debt with the very next
week he proposed so I was able to go
into engagement debt for what's
interesting about that let's say you
hadn't right and you were gonna bring
debt in right he had positive savings or
it could be the other way around right
lady amass we should switch that out but
what's interesting is the one
savings doesn't worry about it yeah but
the one with the debt is all jammed up
about right because you're embarrassed
it's it's like he said shamed right and
look a shame there's three negative
emotions that drive people's money crazy
shame and guilt and and so grace for
yourself and for the other people in
your life around that is a big deal and
and that's not being codependent that's
not saying I'm going to continue to
endorse your stupidity but because you
had stupid somewhere in your past you
give people shame you know you give
yourself grace and you give your give
others grace in that and then the other
ones cynicism which is where people be
messed over by money people and there
you know that immediately think anybody
talking about money so shyster you know
so Dave Ramsey's a snake oil salesman
all that B's yeah right so but the the
point is is that there's a you know he's
really on to something there Casey is
with recognizing that in her and that
gives you an opportunity because all
relationships are growing or they're
dying and so there's no there's no just
in the middle and so it's what I'm
encouraging you here is to push on this
in a you know it's like in a healing way
yeah
that causes take some steps that cause
healing and that'll move you towards
marriage or it'll move you away from
this relationship one of the two right
and one of the two needs to happen yeah
because it's just hanging out thing it's
there it's not got positive implications
for your future yeah and that's the
reason the budgeting conversation hasn't
gone well anyway so when he's tried to
bring it up it's been this kind of
digging heels in because there's this
this information this hold up this kind
of barrier between I'm sorry I think
they fix that then it's gonna open up a
lot more clarity about the future
the thing is Casey what reason we're
talking about this so at length is that
you know your situation is like
everybody very common that's right yeah
it's everybody and so we got 17 million
people listening to this discussion
right now and it this applies to 15
million of them it's like somewhere in
there people are having this discussion
it's the number one cause of divorce and
disagreement is money and money fights
but
when you cannot agree on your dreams and
your fears you can't agree on hardly
anything and it's all reflected in your
money